familiares y amigos dijeron adiós por
última vez a Pascual Melvin Guayaquil el
adolescente indígena de tres años es el
primer repatriado de los 21
guatemaltecos de la tragedia de Texas en
Estados Unidos el 27 de junio un
empleado municipal de San Antonio
encontró a 67 personas asignadas en un
camión sobrecalentado 48 de ellas que ya
habían fallecido por asfixia y me
llamaron como a las 5:30 de la tarde me
dejo mi compañero y llegó tu hijo no
y no es porsustarte verdad
vi la noticia que pasó una tragedia aquí
en San Antonio y investigo me dijo y yo
ese momento empecé a investigar
que que intente a llamar su celular que
ya no contesta en el otro también ya no
contesta
eh cabal Que ahí van en el tráiler desde
entonces
las autoridades tratan de identificar a
cada una de las víctimas para
entregarlas a sus familias los cuerpos
de 25 de los 26 migrantes mexicanos
fallecidos ya llegaron a su país dentro
de los que están los de estos tres
primos de la localidad de San Marcos a
tequilapano buscaban emigrar a Estados
Unidos para encontrar un trabajo un
mejor remunerado si el trabajo del
mexicano es tan Preciado en los Estados
Unidos no es válido hacerlo de manera
ilegal no es válido que ellos caminen
para la derecha y la autoridad voltee
para la izquierda en Centroamérica la
repatriación de los cuerpos de las
víctimas de Texas te espera que terminen
los próximos días según la organización
internacional para las migraciones desde
2014 unos 6.430 migrantes han muerto
desaparecido en su camino en busca del
llamado sueño americano